how did you come to write the title song
for this movie I got the email from DISA
and the husband's flight to New Zealand
emotional films so did and then I
brought you something I say and yeah it
was a very very quick process could you
imagine writing a title song for another
movie is another director asked you and
if yes what movie all works alright and
what director not anytime soon but I'd
love to Scorsese make another gangster
flick I'd love to be alike demo in
change and what do you think about the
JJ Abrams about the Star Wars movie
that's coming out by us almost and would
you like to sing for Star Wars movie I
don't know if Star Wars movie songs
would work and I would probably be
assassinated by a Star Wars fan if I did
it wrong so yeah I think some start the
first pre Star Wars movies are premium
great and then the last three pretty
hitting this so I don't know what these
ones are going to be like I imagine
they'll be hit and miss but we'll see
Star Wars is like the drug dealers in
the white because you get the good drugs
at the beginning I'll show you the good
drugs and then the people coming back
really bad ones but you keep going back
to try and see being it the good ones
again so Star Wars is gonna be one of
those things where everyone's gonna go
watch it anyway because they they have
faith in it and it was amazing and great
and if it's not then we're gonna watch
legs were single
you